we begin in India where police have
raided the homes of several journalists
at more than 30 locations in and around
New Delhi the journalists are associated
with the news website news click a case
has been filed against the website under
an anti-terror law it comes after the
New York Times alleged in August that
news click received funding from a
businessman with links to China and
promoted pro-beijing talking points the
journalists say police have confiscated
their laptops and their phones
while the Press Club of India has
reacted on the social media platform X
it said the Press Club of India is
deeply concerned about the multiple
raids conducted on the houses of
journalists and writers associated with
news click and that we are monitoring
the developments and will be releasing a
detailed statement well we can actually
speak to Gautam Lahiri who is the
president of the Press Club of India he
joins us now from New Delhi many thanks
for your time sir I understand you were
quite surprised when you heard about
these raids can you tell us a bit more
about who these journalists are exactly
that have been targeted
uh thank you very much actually many of
the journalists are very senior and
Veteran generally they are in the
profession for more than 30 years
some of them are very close to us and
many of them are members of Press Club
of India they take part activity in the
club activities particularly on the
issue of media freedom
so uh we are really uh very concerned
about the way the uh security agencies
has sloped into their houses in the
early morning and taken away to an
unknown destination uh some sources are
saying that they are taken into some
custody where they are being
interrogative about the link between the
so-called eligibly channeling uh news
reporter but that's why we have asked
the government to come out in details so
that we can take a further view on this
issue
[Music]
if I understand correctly the the
authorities have used a terror law uh or
have cited a terror law in order to
carry out these raids am I right
yeah yeah that's true that's true even
in our uh you know Press Club manifests
to manuals we have said we have urged in
the government they generally should not
be booked under the anti-terror law if
anyone is found in violation of any
Indian Financial nurse or any other laws
of the land they can take actions but
why the journalists are we are
dubbed under termed as a terrorist or
the terrorists are being taken under
that law where the journalists are
booked under same law so that's why it's
a clear
statement we are asking for and
demanding from the government government
should come out clean so that no wrong
perception goes around the world that
government is soaking or muzzling the
medium medium medium freedom of media
and let's look at these allegations that
were made by the New York Times back in
August that the funding of this website
comes from a U.S millionaire who's
pushing these pushing some sort of
Chinese agenda propaganda it is overseas
funding for a News website illegal in
India
well the website is legal it is not bad
it is not banned sometimes the security
agencies have graded their organizations
or
they have been retained by the bullies
and asked after that they have let them
be they are doing their job
but the point is when the allegation
about delegation there is an ongoing
case uh in the uh board Indian port and
the court is hearing about these cases
where the our portal has clearly said
it's a completely false statement that
they are being funded by some Chinese
agencies or no Chinese element so we are
not sure about those case unless the
Indian Court gives a clear verdict of
decision
and tell us a little bit more about this
website news click how long has it been
around tell us about its reporting and
why you are so concerned now about how
these journalists have been treated
generally the music is very uh this
photo is very critical about the
functioning of the present government at
the center that's a bgp the government
and they are doing some stories which
definitely annoy the government
sometimes the government also says that
they are very biased in reporting so
there is a sometimes their report might
be wrong I am not denying that but point
is then government should have a many
ways to counter those statements or
counter those stories it is not the way
that the police should act on which are
like this whether they're right or wrong
unless they have highlighted any India
law as they have already told you so
they are functioning quite sure
sometimes in this country and they are
very popular indeed uh some of the
stories are like going to be people
obviously government or programming
people don't like their stories
that's the democracy all about that you
have to agree or agree to disagree
indeed good to have you on the program
president of the Press Club of India
speaking to us there from New Delhi
thank you
thank you thank you very much